hey what is up guys and kabhi HD here
and I just think about a week off for
spring break you might have noticed that
hasn't been a video in a week and while
I was away I've kind of realized take a
step back and there haven't been any
giveaways in a while so this is one of
those this is a giveaway an
international giveaway then anyone can
enter and anyone can win I always love
doing these this is going to be what I'm
calling the letter number flagship
giveaway so this is a giveaway of the m9
or the s6 that would be the HTC One m9
or the Samsung Galaxy s6 so to get
entered I'll have it super super simple
all you have to do you see that comment
section right below that like button
click wide open comments section all I
have to do is leave the name of which
phone you would like to win so m9 or s6
and also it comes in a couple colors the
m9 comes in four colors and the s6 also
comes in four colors so leave the color
before the name of the phone you want to
win so if you want to win the blue
galaxy s6 then say in the comment blue
s6 or if you want to win the silver m9
then say silver m9 one comment per
person will be counted so don't enter a
bunch of times I'll disqualify you and
the winner will be announced on Twitter
so follow below they're on April 12th so
by then both phones should be out and
also the review of both of these devices
will be out there's also a galaxy s6
edge all these should be out by then and
also the reviews are actually currently
in the works make sure you hit that
subscribe button if you haven't already
to be among the first to see those when
they come out and that's it that's all
you have to do to get enter there's no
other requirements nothing else fancy no
forms you have to fill out or sharing or
anything special obviously hitting the
like button is appreciated but it's not
required to enter and that's that's
basically it so good luck many will
enter of course one very lucky person
will win hope you enjoy these thanks for
watching
I'll talk to you guys in the next one
peace
[Music]